[Music]
it is this absolute and universal
inversion an alienation of the actual
world and a thought it is pure culture
what is learned in this world is that
neither the actuality of power and
wealth nor of their specific notions
good and bad or the consciousness of
good and bad and Noble and the ignoble
consciousness possessed truth on the
contrary all these moments become
inverted one changing into the other and
each is the opposite of itself the
universal power which is the substance
when it acquires a spiritual nature of
its own through the principle of
individuality receives its own self
merely as a name and through it is the
actualities of power is really the
powerless being that sacrifices its own
self but this expendable selfless being
or the self that has become a thing is
rather than return of that being into
itself it is a being for self that is
explicitly for itself the concrete
existence of spirit the thoughts of
these two essences of good and bad are
similarly inverted in this movement what
is characterized as good as bad and vice
versa the consciousness of each of these
moments the consciousness is judged as
noble and ignoble are rather than their
truth just as much the reverse of what
these characterizations are supposed to
be the noble consciousness is ignoble
and repudiated just as the repudiated
consciousness changes around into the
nobility which characterizes the most
highly developed freedom of self
consciousness from a formal standpoint
everything is outwardly the reverse of
what it is for itself and again it is
not in truth what it is for itself but
something else that it wants to be being
for self is rather the loss of itself in
its self alienation rather the
preservation of itself what we have here
then is that all the moments execute a
universal justice on one another each
just as much at alienates its own self
as it
warms itself into its opposite and in
this way inverts it true spirit however
is justice unity of the absolutely
separate moments and indeed it is just
through the free actuality of these
selfless extremes that as their middle
term it achieves a concrete existence
and exists in the universal talk and
destructive judgement which strips of
their significance all those moments
which are supposed to count as the true
being and as actual members of the whole
and is equally this Neil istic game
which it plays with itself this judging
and talking is therefore what is true
and invincible while it overpowers
everything it is solely with this alone
that one has truly to do within this
actual world in this world the spirit of
each part finds expression or as wittily
talked about and find said about in what
it is the honest individual takes each
moment to be an abiding essentiality and
is the uneducated thoughtlessness of not
knowing that it is equally doing the
reverse the disrupted consciousness
however is consciousness of the
perversion and moreover of the absolute
perversion what prevails in it is the
notion which brings together in a unity
the thoughts which in the honest
individual lie far apart and its
language is therefore a clever and witty
with this long paragraph number 521
we're getting close to the end of this
this first section in this culture
discussion that that runs through so
much of the spirit section of the work
we're only five more paragraphs after
this one is finished before we move into
the next subsection and this is one
where Hegel is bringing together a
number of different thematic so that
we've run through and you might say
giving us a bit of like something like a
summary but it's going beyond just a
summarization of what has taken place
we're now at the point where we're
spirit realizes something rather
Universal about the realm of culture at
least culture as it's gotten to know it
so far building and we've had a lot of
discussion about exactly what culture
comprises here culture is showing itself
as involving as Hegel says an inversion
of her Karen and an alienation and and
time them a becoming other becoming
alien to itself the self you might say
of the individual who's been trying to
figure out where he fits in and what his
meaning is has lost its moorings not
only has the self done so but the very
categories by which the self was
orienting itself turn out to have this
same problematic going on as as we'll
see as we go into this text so angle
tells us in this it is in this absolute
and universal so across the board right
total absolute and universal inversion
and alienation of what of the actual
world and thought he says it is pure
culture hyena culture right a hyena
build them what is learnt in this world
he says is
and here we get these three different
things so he sums it up first saying
what is learned in this world is neither
the actuality of power and wealth state
power that is right neither their their
veer cliff kite nor their specific
notions the concepts that we form of
them namely those of the good and the
bad nor the consciousness of good and
bad which he clarifies for us is the
noble and ignoble consciousness possess
truth let's pause for just a moment what
does this mean to say that they don't
possess truth does this mean that
they're all thereby false
well false in what sense are we talking
about truth in the traditional sense of
an equation between thought and and
being or thought and actuality it turns
out if we follow these dialectical
developments it's not possible they have
a static you know remaining in place add
equation or correspondence of that sort
we would have to have a actuality that's
as shifting as thought is and just as
deep and reflective we would have to
have a thought that follows along the
developments in the actuality of
whatever it is that we're taking here
but that's not actually what Hegel means
here by truth he's talking about
something more comprehensive remember
truth for Hegel is almost always going
to be opposed to certainty to this
height you know if our height and give
this height and you rarely get both of
them at the same time although you're
always striving to have both of them at
the same time you start out with
certainty you try to get you know the
greater truth that that fits into and
then the parts don't all map on to each
other and you figure that out now you've
got the truth but you've lost the
certainty over here sometimes we're
fortunate enough to come to a close
where we have both of them at the same
time we almost wind up with the opposite
of that in in the form that spirit is
taking here
conscious of itself as pure culture so
he tells us looking at each of these
right on the contrary all the moments
become inverted they become turned on
their heads you might say or turned
around each changes into the other and
each is the opposite of itself this is
two different things but they're being
subsumed into this dialectic each is the
opposite of itself each gets turned into
the other and if you think this through
how can something both be turned into
its other and be the opposite of itself
at the same time it's almost those of
its there's two different kinds of
negation going on here that yield us yet
a different relation between the
opposite of itself and the you might say
alienation of itself very interesting
Hegel doesn't doesn't work this out any
further at this point but that's worth
keeping in mind so then in terms of
talking about each of these in turns so
he talks about the universal power which
is the substance when it acquires a
spiritual nature of its own through the
principle of individuality receives its
own self merely as a name though it is
the actuality of power what was this
this was the unlimited monarch of state
power it turns out to be really the
powerless being that sacrifices its own
self what lies behind this this monarch
and you know here Hegel is sort of
deploying a kind of historical you know
what would we call it he's being kind of
coy here it turns out that wealth always
is the power behind the throne at least
in modern politics that we've moved into
you know the king can't be the absolute
monarch without the Parliament and when
the King pushes too hard
wealth pushes back Parliament has the
ability to tax and to dispense I don't
know that we want to go too far with
this but that that's one thing that
would fit what Hegel is talking about
then he says this expendable selfless
being or the self that has become a
thing as rather
the return of that being into itself it
is being for itself that is explicitly
for itself the concrete existence of
spirit the individual on the one hand
wealth on the other then he says okay
put that dynamic aside wealth and state
power what we started this whole section
with what next the thoughts so now we've
moved now from actuality of your clique
height into thought the thoughts of
these two essences of good and bad
become inverted he says turned around
what is characterized as good is bad and
vice-versa how do we know this to be the
case we've seen it play itself out
throughout this section but we also know
that nothing that truly is billed as
good ever turns out to encompass
goodness as such there's always a as
they say a fly in the ointment or a worm
in the Apple
there's badness involved in it and often
as things proceed on we find the good
turning into the bad what may be good at
one point in time becomes bad through
the processes of social change or vice
versa what was bad eventually in some
respect becomes lauded as good
recognized by consciousness as such then
he says the consciousness is of each of
these moments the consciousness is
judged as noble and ignoble the same
thing applies to them he says they're
just the reverse of what these
characterizations are supposed to be the
noble consciousness is ignoble and
repudiated the repudiated consciousness
changes round into nobility which
characterizes the most highly developed
freedom of self consciousness here
something different is happening so the
noble consciousness got revealed at
several
points as not being quite so noble as it
pretends to be even before we got to the
flattery and and we have the service of
flattery and then later on base flattery
this use of language we already saw that
there was something for itself that the
noble consciousness in its service to
the state power was reserving for itself
it became the vassal who had its own you
know game going on on its own
dimensa-zam wouldn't quite give
everything up that's why the state power
Corral's them in at the court and
compels them to be sort of satellites
around it within a system so the noble
consciousness isn't as noble as it
claims to be as a matter of fact it
turns out that as Hegel said earlier the
distinction between noble and ignoble
consciousness winds up being effaced and
once we bring wealth into the picture it
gets even trickier right the noble
consciousness has to take stuff from
wealth but when you're bought the person
who's buying you seems to think that
they own you and you're placed in a one
down position as the one who was
benefited from the benefactor or what
about the ignoble consciousness the
ignoble consciousness really hasn't
gotten to talk very much throughout this
entire dialectic in this section here
again let me read what Hegel wrote us
the repudiated consciousness changes
around into the nobility which
characterizes the most highly developed
freedom of self-consciousness what is
this most highly developed freedom
that's going to come a little bit later
so let's look at what's happening in the
second part of this paragraph Hegel now
talks about things he says from a formal
standpoint says everything is outwardly
the reverse of what it is for itself
every one of these is for itself and yet
each one of them by being for itself has
a loss
itself and has an alienation from itself
a becoming other becoming different and
distant you might say from itself now
notice what he calls this here he says
what we have here is that all the
moments execute a universal justice on
one another isn't that an interesting
way to talk each one of them is
executing justice on one another how so
each of them is revealing what it is
that the other really is it's showing it
up it's unmasking it it's telling us the
other consciousness looking on what
these things are for themselves as
they'd like to present themselves and
thereby what they really are in
themselves the in itself of the for
itself is not reconciled here in any of
these so he says true spirit is the
unity of these absolutely separate
moments true spirit is the unity of all
of these how can that be the case this
is where we're going to get back to the
ignoble consciousness so he says it is
through the free actuality these
selfless extremes that as their middle
term it achieves a concrete existence
spirit takes on concrete existence takes
on flesh takes on individuality exists
in the world so what does it exist him
he says it exists in the universal talk
this frakkin talking back and forth and
Hegel is going to use cognate snouts
frakkin you know like like to Express
ouch frakkin right throughout the rest
of this it exists in the universal talk
and the destructive judgment which
strips of their significance all those
moments which are supposed to count as
the true being and as actual members of
the whole now here you might get a
little excited with
Miller's translation but we have to be a
little bit careful Hague Allah does not
actually use the term nihilism or
nihilistic here there were some people
in in Const I'm already in fixed this
time who were easing Jakob E famously
used that word as a criticism of the
conscient
and really by extension all of trip and
idealistic philosophy but it didn't
really didn't have a wide currency and
Miller is stretching it here a little
bit because the word that's being used
here is is you know cognitive out haben
right so sublation something is being
nullified right so he says you know it's
this game that it plays with itself so
this judging and talking is therefore
what is true the true and true spirit is
its use of language and its use of
judgment or tile now who is carrying
this out is it some other person outside
of this entire dynamic it's actually the
ignoble consciousness this is where it
comes on the scene and asserts itself as
where the development is continuing to
take place let's go back now a little
bit changes around into the nobility
which characterizes it as the most
highly developed freedom of self
consciousness
that's what spirit is bringing to this
so he says it's solely with this alone
that one has to truly to do in this
actual world in this world the world of
pure culture not pure culture in the
sense of culture de rasa nated and you
know store it away on bookshelves or
something like that culture as it's
actually being lived thought out worked
through consumed in this world he says
the spirit of each part finds expression
how so it's wittily talked about and
fine said about it what it is each of
these
finds somebody providing it with its own
truth state power doesn't really know
what it is it likes to think of itself
in a certain way but it's in the coffee
shops which sometimes they try to close
that the king or the nobility discover
who they really are it's in the
broadsheets likewise wealth wealth
doesn't truly know what it is the people
who are wealthy don't truly understand
who they are the noble consciousness
perhaps even a large portion of the base
consciousness the person who's a peasant
the person who's a worker the person who
is a bastard an orphan doesn't realize
that they have a larger role to play if
they're allowed their moment on the
scene if spirit worked through that so
again he says the honest individual
takes each moment to be an abiding
essentiality and it is the uneducated
thoughtlessness of not knowing that it
is equally doing the reverse the honest
individual is a dupe at this point
doesn't fully understand the way the
world the actuality works the honest
individual expects things to go
according to how they used to be talked
about or how they're simplistically
talked about not how they are wittily
talked about the disrupted consciousness
he says however is consciousness of the
perversion and moreover of the absolute
perversion what prevails in it is the
notion which brings together in a unity
the thoughts which in the honest
individual life are two part the the
honest individual suffers from you might
say separated categories that can't be
bridged into each other but the other
consciousness the disrupted
consciousness has a language that is
clever and witty which can connect these
things together and thereby even though
it seems like it's just kind of you know
biessing you know as we say shooting the
breeze
it's actually revealing the truth of all
of the
important moments within culture
the content of what spirit says about
itself is thus the perversion of every
notion and reality the universal
deception of itself and others and the
shamelessness which gives utterance to
this deception is just for that reason
the greatest truth this kind of talk is
the madness of the musician who heaped
up and mixed together 30 arias
italian-french tragic comic of every
sort now with a deep base he descended
into hell then contracting his throat
here ends the vaults of heaven with a
falsetto tone frantic and soothed
imperious and mocking by turns to the
tranquil consciousness which in its
honest way takes the melody of the good
and the true to consist in the evenness
of the notes that is in unison this talk
abuses a rigmarole of wisdom and folly
as a medley of as much skill as baseness
of his many correct as false ideas a
mixture compounded of a complete
perversion of sentiment of the absolute
shamelessness and a perfect frankness of
truth it will be unable to refrain from
entering into all these tones and
running up and down the entire scale of
feelings from the profoundest contempt
and dejection to the highest pitch of
admiration and emotion but blended with
the latter will be a tinge of ridicule
which spoils them the former however
will find in their very frankness a
strain of reconciliation will find in
their subversive depths the all-powerful
know which restores spirit to itself
here in paragraph 522 were treated to
something that we don't often come
across in Hegel's phenomenology and that
is not just an illusion or a brief
mention but actual quotation of some
text in this case it is of Denis Diderot
's Ramos nephew if you haven't read
Diderot he's really a very interesting
author he is writing you know in the
time of the the French monarchy he's one
of the encyclopedias whose work is
ultimately going to lead to not just the
French Revolution in general but also to
the greater enlightenment that is taking
place and Diderot was somebody who
really had quite a good comic sense as
well as being quite a serious guy in
many other respects interestingly might
my favorite work by him is one that's
equally interesting it's called jacques
khalifa to the east they saw might you
know jack the fatalist and his master
which is a picaresque novel the Rommels
nephew is a little bit more biting it's
it's about these you might call them
parasitical people who are sort of
trying to figure out where they they fit
into society and and you know when that
sort of thing is on the scene that's a
sign that there's something wrong
something not really worked out but
something dynamic within that society we
might think of many other great works of
literature if you haven't read Diderot
i would say that if you wanted to pick
somebody who would be kind of a
contemporary in doing this you could
think of somebody like tom wolfe perhaps
others might have other great
suggestions as well so Hegel tells us
that the content of what Spirit says
about itself saying it through the
ignoble consciousness
is thus the he's going to say three
things the perversion the fear Kieran of
every notion everybody and reality
reality tat in this case the universal
deception batuque of once of itself and
of others and here's where it gets
really interesting here's where the
truth of spirit true spirit is coming on
the scene through language the
shamelessness which gives utterance to
this deception is just for that reason
the greatest truth this shamelessness
expresses this deception
it doesn't just enact the deception
it also unveils the fact that deception
is taking place this is going to lead
ultimately to what Hagel is calling a
frankness an orphan height being open
about things is this a good thing is
this a bad thing it is a good thing in a
sense but it's also you might say for
many people something terrible because
it's the sign that nothing truly is what
it pretends to be everything is
susceptible to being unmasked now that's
not where Hegel's going with this
instead he talks about a proliferation a
profusion of different content so here's
where he starts quoting Diderot says
this kind of talk is the madness of the
musician who here is the line heaped up
and mixed together thirty
Arya's italian french tragicomic of
every sort so he's taking all of these
different which should be distinct
genres of things what in the just in the
last passage we talked about well stay
power the noble consciousness the
ignoble conscience is good bad mixing
them all up together producing a
composite picture
you might say then Hegel says now are
the deep bassy de senate in health and
contracting authority rent the vaults of
heaven with a falsetto tone frantic and
soothed imperious and mocking by turns
this is a virtuoso a virtuoso of
imitation a virtuoso who is able to take
bits and pieces of what it is that
others have taken seriously and done for
their own sake you know it's interesting
this is a bit of a digression here there
is a lot of people that throw around the
word postmodern basically as a slur word
today I think without really recognizing
what's meant by it and and I'm not going
to go into a long thing about the
different types of postmodern you can
read jamison and his wonderful analysis
in in his work on the postmodern for
that suffice it to say that the kind of
pastiche that the ironic detachment that
is often seen as the hallmark of the
aesthetic postmodern that's already here
being described and discussed by Hegel
who's gotten it from Diderot who's not
just making it up himself but getting it
from the culture that he inhabits in the
very heart of the modern and not even
the late modern so this is actually kind
of an important point here so again
Hegel brings up the tranquil
consciousness in its honest way which
wants the melody of the good and the
true to consist in the evenness of the
notes some sort of comprehensive you
know this just just if you've got a play
jazz just play jazz don't mix it
together with country or funk or folk or
whatever it happens to be right let
alone world music just play that the
pure thing so I know what we're doing
here and might be saying he says this
talk appears now who is he talking about
is the talk the talk of the
singer no the talk now is the talk of
the ignoble consciousness this talk he
says appears as a rigmarole of wisdom
and folly as a medley of as much skill
as baseness of as many correct as false
ideas a mixture compounded of a complete
perversion of sentiment of absolute
shamelessness and perfect frankness and
truth once again we see these three
themes turning up don't we it will be
unable to refrain from entering into all
these tones and running up and down the
entire range of scale of feelings from
their profound is contempt and objection
to the highest pitch of admiration and
emotion but blended with the latter
notice will be a tinge of ridicule which
spoils them so again we've got a
virtuoso now a virtuoso you might say of
the life of the heart and of the mind
but with a sort of ironic detachment
they can take on whatever emotional
comportment seems needed or perhaps
interesting or perhaps amusing in the
situation but they do so without fully
committing to it you might say well this
is the opposite of truth Hegel says this
is the truth of culture at this point so
this is an openness a frankness a being
willing to call things what they are to
show them for what they are as not being
what they pretend to be what they are
pretended to be by those who identify
with them again the postmodern present
here already in culture not at the end
of Hegel's discourse but right in the
middle of it so he goes on he says the
former who is the former the former is
the person who can see their way through
this will find in their very frankness a
strain of reconciliation reconciliation
the opposite of alienation will find in
their subs or subversive deaths the
all-powerful note which restores spirit
to itself
this is not the end this is not a
resting place but this is a forward
movement in the eyes of Hegel
you